IF WE CAN HAVE ALL SENATORS
PLEASE REPORT O THE FLOOR
MISTER SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CAPPIELLO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
THE ROUTE SO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HILL.
WITH SO [inaudible]
OR TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BUT MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER BY CASKEY WIENER.
WILK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A SECRETARY
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WE'RE GONNA ASK SERGEANTS PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS HERE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AT THEIR OFFICES WITH THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE GAS BEYOND THE
RAIL AND GALLERY PLEASE RIGHTS.
WOULD BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR FANTASTIC
CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH SENATORS WERE GONNA
ASK YOU TO PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING BURKE IN THE LEAD IN
THE NATION'S PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR SKINNER.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
CHRISTA MCAULIFFE SAID TO
TEACHERS TO TOUCH THE FUTURE.
AND SO TEACH US YOUR WAYS
GRACIOUS GODS.
THOSE WE MAY BE OPEN TO THAT
SAME SPIRIT.
WHO MOVED IN THE LIVES OF OUR
TEACHERS? TO LEAD US FROM
UNCONSCIOUSNESS TO WONDER AND
AWE.
AND SEVERE WEARING THOSE THOSE
WE TOO CAN BRING ORDER AND
BEAUTY.
INTO THE CHAOS OF OUR WORLD.
TEACH US YOUR WAYS WITH THE
PATIENCE OF OUR TEACHERS.
BUT WE MAY PRAISE YOU AND THEM
FOR THE WONDROUS GIFTS WE HAVE
RECEIVED.
GIVES OF CREATIVITY OF COURAGE
OF JUSTICE AND HUMAN KINDNESS.
TEACH US YOUR WAYS THIS REMAKE
DEEPEN OUR COMMITMENT TO THE
HEALING OF OUR WORLD.
FROM THE CONSEQUENCES OF BROKEN
DREAMS AND BROKEN PROMISES.
MAY ALREADY DO TODAY BRING
GLADNESS AND HOPE.
INTO THE LIVES OF ALL WHO LOOK
TO US FOR LEADERSHIP AND TO LIVE
A MAN.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE AMERICA.
GEN.
THIS IS
.
MEMBERS WE WELCOME.
WHAT ME TO THE FLOOR AND OF
COURSE?
TO OUR FAVORITE DAY OF THE
SEASON WITH APPROPRIATIONS DAY --
WE ARE GOING TO BE MOVING TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT SENATOR LEYVA IS
GONNA BE PRESENTING A VERY
SPECIAL RESOLUTION ON A VERY
SPECIAL.
ONE HUNDRED YEAR ANNIVERSARY
CENTER LABOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
RECOGNIZE THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS THE C. F.
T..
THE SAFETY IS A UNION OF
EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFY
PROFESSIONALS THAT WAS FOUNDED
IN NINETEEN NINETEEN AND WILL BE
CELEBRATING ITS ONE HUNDREDTH
YEAR ANNIVERSARY.
THIS YEAR ON MAY THIRTY FIRST
SEE IF TùIS COMPRISED OF MORE
THAN ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
AFFILIATED MEMBERS INCLUDING A
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE LOCAL
UNIONS.
CHARTER BY THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND EDUCATIONAL EMPLOYEES
AT EVERY LEVEL OF EDUCATION FROM
HEAD START TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT THE C.
F. T. HELP HOUSE LANDMARK HIGHER
LET EDUCATION.
THE LANDMARK MARK HIGHER
EDUCATION EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS ACT BRING THE BENEFITS
OF COLLECTIVE BARGAINING TO
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYEES.
I AM HONORED TO RECOGNIZE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS COMMITTED
TO PROMOTING HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION AND PROVIDING SERVICE
TO CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATORS AND
STUDENTS.
WITH US TODAY WE HAVE FOUR OF
SEE IF HE'S LEADERS MANY OF WHOM
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
WITH WHAT I WAS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
CFT PRESIDENT JOSH PENCILED
SECRETARY TREASURER AND
PRESIDENT ELECT JEFF REDUCE
SECRETARY TREASURER ELECT
LUCKIEST SMITH AND SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT LACI BARNES PLEASE
JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING CF. ONE
HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY AND
WELCOMING THE CFT LEADERS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. ONE HUNDRED YEARS
STRONG REGULATIONS. FORTY
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK.
WE INVITE ALL MEMBERS TO BE
UNDERTAKEN OFFICIALS SENATE
FOTOGRAFIJE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
GATHER AT THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBERS FOR AN OFFICIAL SENATE
PHOTOGRAPH
.
BUT OTHER BIG CONGRATULATIONS TO
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS.
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW.
FOR THANK A LITTLE BIT OF TIME.
TO SHOP FOR SOME CONGRADULATIONS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE.
A IN IN JUST A MOMENT WILL BE
TRANSITIONING TO SENATOR
PORTANTINO IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO CALL
YOUR ATTENTION TO CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO CENTER PORTANTINO.
WITH A VERY IMPORTANT
RECOGNITION.
SAN PORTANTINO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES -- THE FOLLOWING
ON THE WONDERFUL RECOGNITION OF
A CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS -- THERE'S ALSO A
BITTER SWEET -- RECOGNITION OF
THEIR PRESIDENT -- WHO IS
RETIRING -- A I'VE HAD.
POINT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE A
REALLY NICE MAN -- HE REALLY IS.
YEAH AND YOU KNOW.
AND I HAVE MY FATHER NEVER GOT
TO RETIRE -- ME DIED BEFORE HE
COULD RETIRE AND I JUST LOVE IT
WHEN PEOPLE ABOUT A PROUD RECORD
OF ACCOMPLISHMENT.
AND THEY GET TO RETIRE AND THEY
GET TO ENJOY THEIR FAMILY AND SO
IT'S MY HONOR TO RECOGNIZE AND
CONGRATULATE -- CFT PRESIDENT
JOSH WHAT PUSHED ALL ON HIS
CAREER AND CONGRATULATE HIM ON
HIS RETIREMENT.
JOSH WAS REELECTED PRESIDENT FOR
THE FOURTH TIME OF THIS.
LOCAL OF ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBER CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS IN MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AFTER SERVING
SIX YEARS AS PRESIDENT.
OF UT LA A. F. T. LOCAL TEN
TWENTY ONE AS PRESIDENT HE WAS
CHAIR OF CFCS FIGHT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE TASK FORCE.
THAT ORGANIZED HISTORIC SEVEN
WEEK MARCH IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN THROUGH CALIFORNIA'S
CENTRAL VALLEY TO SHINE A LIGHT
ON THE STATE'S DEVASTATING
BUDGET CUTS TO EDUCATION AND
SOCIAL SERVICES.
HE'S BEEN INVOLVED IN VARIOUS
COALITION EFFORTS INCLUDING THE
CHAIR OF U. T. L. A.'S SCHOOL
COMMUNITY RELATIONS COMMITTEE
THE STOP THE CUTS COALITION AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
EDUCATION COALITION.
HE PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN CREATING
THE RE CLAIM CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE
COALITION OF LABOR AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS THAT WAS INSTRUMENTAL.
IN PASSING CALIFORNIA'S PROP
THIRTY IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
WHICH MANY OF US WHO WERE HERE
DURING THE TIMES OF THE CUTS NO.
WAS A KEY FACTOR IN KEEPING OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM STABLE AND
KEEPING CALIFORNIA ON THE RIGHT
TRACK.
WHEN EFFORTS IN THE PAST HAD
FAILED JOSH WAS A KEY PLAYER TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT HAPPENED
HE'S CURRENTLY A MEMBER OF THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE OF THE LABOR
COMMITTEE COALITION LOOKING TO
REFORM CALIFORNIA'S?
TAX STRUCTURE AGAIN IN A FURTHER
INCIDENT EFFORT TO HELP PUBLIC
EDUCATION WHICH IS SOMETHING WE
ALL HOLD DEAR.
IN HIS PERSONAL EDUCATION
ACCOMPLISHMENTS HE WAS AN
ENGLISH TEACHER -- INK TAUGHT
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE FOR
TWO YEARS IN CALLIE COLUMBIA AND
A SOCIAL STUDIES TEACHER FOR
TWENTY ONE YEARS AT MANUAL ARTS
HIGH SCHOOL IN LOS ANGELES HE
EARNED A BACHELOR OF ARTS DEGREE
IN PHILOSOPHY AND MAYBE THAT'S
WHY.
HE'S SUCH A NICE MAN.
HE'S ACTUALLY A PHILOSOPHER FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SANTA CRUZ AND A MASTER'S OF
ARTS DEGREE IN LATIN AMERICAN
STUDIES FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
WISCONSIN AT MADISON HE AND HIS
WIFE ELAINE.
ARE THE PROUD PARENTS OF A
DAUGHTER WHO ATTENDED HIGH
SCHOOL IN LA UNIFIED AND
CURRENTLY ATTENDS OUR BILL IN
COLLEGE AND HE SHARES MANY
STORIES ABOUT HER SO WE SHOULD.
ALSO NOTE HE'S A PROUD DAD ON
TOP OF EVERYTHING HE'S DONE TO
MAKE OUR STATE GREATER SO
COLLEAGUES IT JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING IN CONGRATULATING
JOSH FOR STALLED.
ON A ABSOLUTELY MARVELOUS CAREER
AS A FATHER TEACHER EDUCATOR AND
PROUD PROGRESSIVE ACTIVIST.
IT'S OFFER A CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
BEHALF OF YOUR CAREER
.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS AND WE
WELCOME ALL SENATORS VERY TAKEN
OFFICIAL SENATE PHOTOGRAPH.
WITH THE SHORT TIMER
[inaudible]
SO THE
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE SOME VERY SPECIAL GUESTS
IN THE GALLERY HERE TODAY.
I SEE ON THE FLOOR EXCUSE ME TOO
SCHOLAR ATHLETES.
WHICH CENTER MY NAME.
IN LEADER GROW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO INTRODUCE CENTER MONEY
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS ALL LEAD OFF AN ARM BE.
FOLLOWED BY OUR MINORITY LEADER --
MEMBERS IT'S MY GREAT PLEASURE
TO INTRODUCE GRACE MAINLY.
AT TWENTY NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION
SCHOLAR ATHLETE OF THE YEAR.
THIS PROGRAM ANNUALLY RECOGNIZES
TO STUDENT ATHLETES BASED ON
THEIR ACHIEVEMENTS IN ATHLETICS
ACADEMICS AND CHARACTER.
IN THIS YEAR'S SCHOLAR ATHLETES
WERE SELECTED FROM A POOL OF TWO
HUNDRED FORTY THREE CANDIDATES.
GRACE IS A THREE SPORT ATHLETE A
SO CAL HIGH SCHOOL AND HAS
SERVED AS TEAM CAPTAIN OF THE
SOCCER.
CROSS COUNTRY AND TRACK TEAMS
THE PAST TWO YEARS.
SHE'S RECEIVED NUMEROUS AWARDS
INCLUDING A P. SCHOLAR WITH
DISTINCTION AND NATIONAL
HISPANIC RECOGNITION SCHOLAR.
THIS FALL GRACE WILL ATTEND
VANDERBILT UNIVERSITY IN ORDER
TO PURSUE A DEGREE IN MEDICINE.
HEALTH AND SOCIETY OR BIOMEDICAL
ENGINEERING.
SHE'S AN INCREDIBLY TALENTED
YOUNG WOMAN SHE'S JOINED TODAY
BY HER PARENTS CHARLES AND JULIE
BAILEY AND HER GRANDMOTHER CAROL
BAILEY I ASKED YOU JOIN ME IN
GIVING A WARM WELCOME AND
CONGRATULATIONS. TO GRACE
FAILING.
CONGRATULATIONS GRAYSON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
[inaudible] FOR YEAH.
OKAY I JUST WANTED JONES SAWYER.
AND WE WELCOME ALL SENATORS TO
BE ABLE TO JOIN CENTER MINING
GRACE FOR AN OFFICIAL SENATE
PHOTOGRAPH [inaudible]
WE SO WE WILL HAVE GRACE WAIT AT
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBERS WHERE
SHE'S OUT THERE NOW.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
TURN EITHER GROVE WILL NOW
INTRODUCE THE MALE SCHOLAR
ATHLETE AND THEN WE'LL GET THEM
ALL TOGETHER.
LEADER GROWTH THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MADAM LATER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I AM
PLATE I'M PLEASED TO RECOGNIZE
MISTER PARKER BOSWELL A SENIOR
AT EL DIAMANTE HIGH SCHOOL IN BY
CELL YET CALIFORNIA HE'S A MALE
STUDENT ATHLETE OF THE YEAR FOR
C. I. F..
PARKER'S AN HONOR STUDENT AT AN
A. P. STUDENT BUT ALSO
INCREDIBLY INVOLVED IN HIS
COMMUNITY.
AS A TWO SPORT ATHLETE AT EL
DIAMANTE HIGH SCHOOL PARKER'S
PARTICIPATED IN BOTH BASEBALL
AND FOOTBALL FOR THE PAST FOUR
YEARS.
SERVING AS A TEAM CAPTAIN FOR
THREE YEARS NOT ONLY IS PARKER
ACTIVE IN THE FIELD IN HIS
CLASSROOM BUT HE HAS ALSO SERVED
IN STUDENT GOVERNMENT AS A AS BE
PRESIDENT SB TREASURE.
AND A CLASS PRESIDENT DURING
BOTH HIS FRESHMAN AND JUNIOR
YEARS.
PARKER IS ALSO SERVED AS AN
ELECTED STUDENT REPRESENTATIVE
TO THE LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD THE
FUNDRAISING CHAIR A SCHOOL SITE
COUNCIL MEMBER IN A TUTOR FOR AT
RISK STUDENT ATHLETES IN MATH
AND ENGLISH.
ALL THE WHILE MAINTAINING AN
IMPRESSIVE GPA OF THREE POINT.
NINE THREE PARKER IS GIVEN A
GENEROUS AMOUNT OF TIME TO IS AN
ENERGY TO HIS COMMUNITY HE'S
VOLUNTEERED WITH VALLEY
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL.
AS A CHAIR OF KIDS DAY HE'S
PARTICIPATED FOR SIX YEARS AND
SERVE I SAW YOUR PROGRAM TO
SERVE THE HOMELESS HE'S ALSO
MENTORED IN COACH SPECIAL NEEDS
CHILDREN THROUGH THE MIRACLE
LEAGUE.
AND PARTICIPATED IN A VETERANS
DAY IN VETERANS DAY EVENTS THAT
PAINTED HOUSES FOR THE LOCAL
VETERANS.
IN ADDITION TO SCHOOLWORK AN
EXTRA CURRICULAR ACTIVITIES AND
COMMUNITY SERVICE HE'S ALWAYS
SPENT HE'S ALSO SPENT SUMMERS
WORKING AS A FARM LABOR IN THIS
BEAUTIFUL CENTRAL VALLEY.
ALL OF THESE ACCOMPLISHMENTS DID
NOT COME EASY FOR PARKER AFTER
STRUGGLING TO FIND A NEW NORMAL
WHEN HIS FAMILY FACED TRAGEDY.
PARKER AUDIT WAS DEALT ANOTHER
CHALLENGE WHEN HE WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH MONO IN BED RIDDEN FOR
EIGHT WEEKS.
HOWEVER PARKER WAS RESILIENT HE
BOUNCED BACK AND COMPLETED ALL
OF HIS COURSES ON TIME WITH AN
IMPRESSIVE GPA AND EVEN ACHIEVED
IN A IN HIS COLLEGE COURSE.
THIS YEAR'S SCHOLARSHIP ATHLETES
WERE SELECTED AS MY COLLEAGUE
SAID FROM A POOL OF TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE STUDENTS.
THE PRESTIGIOUS AWARD IS GIVEN
TO ONLY TWO STUDENTS BASED ON
EVELYN AS EXCELLENCE IN
ATHLETICS ACADEMICS AND
CHARACTER.
IT'S EASY TO SEE WHY PARKER IS
MORE DESERVING FOR THIS AWARD
AND SCHOLARSHIP.
I ALSO HAVE NO DOUBT THAT PARK
OVER SUCCEED IN HIS FUTURE
ENDEAVORS PARKER'S ATTENDING
CHAPMAN UNIVERSITY WITH A FULL
RIDE SCHOLARSHIP IN THE FALL AND
WE WISH HIM THE BEST OF LUCK IS
HE FOLLOWS IS STREAMS.
WITH HIM TODAY IS HIS MOM
SHANNON.
HIS MOM SHE AND HIS BROTHER
PRESTON HIS GRANDPARENTS AND
THREE INCREDIBLE MENTORS THAT
ENGAGED IN THIS YOUNG MAN'S LIFE
HIS ATHLETIC COACH ANTHONY ARE
ADAM TOMPKINS.
THE PRINCIPAL OF THE HIGH SCHOOL
JEFF HAHNE LARRY BOY IN A FIVE
ONE IF THEY THE LEARNING
INSTRUCTOR SO TODAY I ASK YOU
COLLEAGUES TO STANDING GIVE A
WARM WELCOME TO BOTH OF THESE
OUTSTANDING STUDENT ATHLETES AND
OUR ATHLETES PARKER BY.
REGULATIONS PARKER'S.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
LADIES IN GERMAN WITH ACTIVATE A
WELCOME ANY AND ALL SENATORS FOR
AN OFFICIAL SENATE PHOTOGRAPH
.
THANK YOU SO MUCH LEADER GROVE
IN SENATOR MINING
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN. TO PARKER
INTEGRATES WE'RE GONNA HAVE ONE
MORE PHOTOGRAPH [inaudible]
WITH.
GRAYSON OR FAMILY WHO ARE SO
PROUD TODAY.
IT WILL MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR
BUSINESS OF THE DAY
.
SENATORS THANK YOU. FOR
RECOGNIZING THOSE SCHOLAR
ATHLETES WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
A TO MOVE FORWARD IN THE FILE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SENATORS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SIR JOINT RULE THIRTY THREE
POINT.
ONE JOINT ROLE SIXTY ONE WILL BE
SUSPENDED.
SUSPENDED TO ALLOW THE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE TO MEET
NEXT WEEK.
AFTER THE DEADLINE.
THIS REQUEST HAS BEEN APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
SENATORS WITHOUT OBJECTION
MEASURES REPORTED FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
WHAT THE RECOMMENDATION DO PASS
WILL BE GIVEN THEIR SECOND
READING UPON BEING REPORTED IN
ORDERED TO THIRD READING?
MEASURES REPORTED TODAY AND
TOMORROW WITH THE RECOMMENDATION
DO PASS AS AMENDED.
WILL BE GIVEN THEIR SECOND
READING AMENDMENTS ADOPTED AND
RETURN TO THE SECOND READING
UPON BEING.
REPORTER FOR MAKING SURE YOU'RE
TAKING NOTES ON THIS IS WHAT
MEMBERS.
OUT WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR MAY THIRTEENTH
THROUGH MAY SEVENTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK.
WE NOW LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE IN THE CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE.
WE'D LIKE TO START WITH THE
SECOND READING FILE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL.
SIX SEVENTY SIX SENATE BILL FOR
NINETY SIX AND SENATE BILL TWO
OH TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SECRETARY.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ITEMS FOUR
THROUGH EIGHT ITEMS FOUR THROUGH.
EIGHT TAGGED AS GOVERNOR
APPOINTMENTS.
CENTER WORKERS PREPARED.
YOU'RE WELCOME THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM FORCE A
CONFIRMATION OF MAKING MCGINNIS
TO THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
CONTROL APPEALS BOARD.
MISS MCGUINNESS'S SERVED ON THE
BOARD SINCE JULY OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND SHE IS AN EXECUTIVE
FREELANCE PRODUCER IN LOS
ANGELES.
SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MAY FIRST ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS DO WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE AT THIS
TIME ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
HEARING SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS.
BATES.
I BILL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG.
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HILL AYE HUESO.
HIGHER TITLE.
BY JACKSON I JONES.
HI LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK I'M A REAL
[inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I NUMBER.
I WOULD COUNTY.
I WINNER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA.
HI.
ATKINS.
WE'RE JUST.
GROW.
HI HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HI
MITCHELL.
BY NIELSEN.
BY WIENER.
CENTER WILL CLOSE THE CALL
MEMBERS WE NOW LIKE TO MOVE ON
TO I FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE CENTER WHAT THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
YOUR PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF DOCTOR DE ENTER BROMONT TO
THE CANNABIS CONTROL APPEALS
PANEL.
DOT TO REMIND IS AN ADJUNCT
LECTURER FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MASTER
SOCIAL WORK PROGRAM.
IN PREVIOUSLY WORKED FOR THE
BROTHERHOOD CRUSADE SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MAY FIRST ON THE UNANIMOUS
VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
SENATORS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN NINE MISTER SECTOR
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I BILL. FIVE OR JUST
[inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
AYE OR TITLE.
BY JACKSON.
I JONES BY [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR I MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M REAL.
AYE NIELSEN.
AYE PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG.
PILOT.
I WINNER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
THIS IS IT MR SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONCE.
ATKINS. FOR JUST [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
WIENER.
CENTER WELCOMES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE NOW THAT I CAN MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM SIX CENTER WOKE
WELCOME BACK [inaudible]
IT'S WILK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM SIX IS A
CONFIRMATION TO KATHERINE
BUCKLIN TO THE COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS.
SONYA AND DELL AND TO THE STATE.
BAR BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND PUBLIC
GARCIA TO THE STATE MINING AND
GEOLOGY BOARD ALL THESE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MAY FIRST
WITH THE UNANIMOUS VOTE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SENATORS WE HAVE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
CENTER HERTZBERG YEAH I JUST
WANT TO JOIN IN ON BEHALF OF THE
CATHARINE BUCKLAND WHO I'VE
KNOWN FOR MANY DECADES AND HOLD
IN THE HIGHEST REGARD AND I'M
VERY HAPPY THE GOVERNOR MADE THE
APPOINTMENT THE RULES COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER MAJORITY LEADER
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR FROM THE
MEMBERS.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
XENON IS SECTOR CAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I BILL.
I PURCHASED BRADFORD.
I CARRY IT ALL.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL
[inaudible]
WHAT'S SO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON.
BY JONES I LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH.
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN AYE STONE.
BY -- BURKE.
I WOULD COUNTY BY WINNER
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
AND IT'S JUST LIKE YOUR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS.
BURGESS HILL AYE.
WIENER.
SENATOR WILL MOVES TO CALL.
MEMBERS.
WOULD LIKE TO TURN YOUR
ATTENTION FILE ITEM.
SEVEN CENTER WHAT.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS A
CONFIRMATION OF MARIA MAJERUS TO
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION MISMATCH ERIS IS THE
STUDENT REPRESENTATIVE ON THE
COMMISSION.
AND SHE CURRENTLY ATTENDS THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MAY FIRST ON THE
UNANIMOUS VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SENATORS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
HI BILL.
I PURCHASED BRADFORD
[inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DOT.
BY THE RISE OF I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GROWTH.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
I OUR TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
BY WHAT COUNTY BY WINNER
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
BY.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS FORTUS [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
WIENER.
SENATOR WILK MOVES THE CALL.
WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL FILE ITEM
UNDER GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT
APPOINTMENTS THAT'S FILE ITEM
EIGHT CENTER WILL.
CARRY SOME.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT THANK YOU SIR FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT IS A CONFIRMATION
AT NATHAN FLETCHER TO THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
MISTER FLETCHER IS A CURRENT
MEMBER OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL BOARD.
HE SERVED IN THE US MARINE CORPS
FROM NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN TO
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND AS AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT TO TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MAY FIRST BY UNANIMOUS FIVE
OH VOTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SENATORS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR.
FINAL CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
HI BILL.
I PURCHASED BRADFORD.
BY COMING AT ALL.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GROWTH.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRE I MITCHELL
[inaudible]
HI MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
BY PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN.
BY STONE.
HI [inaudible]
NUMBER.
IA CATHY I WINNER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE ATKINS.
FORTUS MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
WIENER.
CENTER WILL LOSE THE CALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER WELL.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO TURN YOUR
ATTENTION TO SENATE THIRD
READING WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING THE FILE FILE ITEMS
THIRTEEN THROUGH.
SEVENTY THREE MEMBERS WE LIKE TO
BE A START WITH AT FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN TODAY.
CENTER GLAZER PREPARED TO
PRESENT.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ.
FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY
ONE MESSENGER GLAZER AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GOOD MORNING SENATOR THE FLOOR
IS YOURS.
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- SB FIVE THIRTY ONE
SIXTY AND A PERVERSE INCENTIVE.
IN OUR CURRENT TAX CODE THAT IS
LED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO GIVE
AWAY.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN TAX
REVENUE TO PRIVATE CORPORATIONS.
THESE DEALS TAKE MONEY FROM
EVERY CITY IN THE STATE.
AND GIVE IT TO SOME OF THE
RICHEST CORPORATIONS IN THE
WORLD.
THAT'S JUST WRONG.
UNDER BRADLEY BURNS UNIFORM
LOCAL SALES TAX LAW.
SALES TAX REVENUE IS ALLOCATED
TO THE POINT OF SALE. FOR BRICK
AND MORTAR STORES THIS MEANS
ALLOCATING THE REVENUE TO A
JURISDICTION THE STORE IS
LOCATED IN.
AND WE'RE ALL VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THAT.
ONLINE RETAILERS HOWEVER.
HAD HE ABILITY TO CHOOSE WHERE
THEY ALLOCATE SALES TAX REVENUE.
THE DATA WAREHOUSE THE
DISTRIBUTION CENTER EVEN A SALES
OFFICE.
THIS ALLOWS CORPORATIONS TO
DIRECT REVENUES TO A SINGLE
JURISDICTION IN THE STATE.
NOW CORPORATIONS USE THIS
LEVERAGE WHEN NEGOTIATING TO
LOCATE THEIR BUSINESS SOMEPLACE
IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS RESULTS IN A RIGGED PROCESS.
DRIVING CITIES TO ACCEPT
INCREASINGLY ONEROUS TAX SHARING
AGREEMENTS.
IN EXCHANGE FOR ONLINE RETAILERS
BUILDING OR RELOCATING IN THEIR
JURISDICTION.
UNDER THESE AGREEMENTS PRIVATE
COMPANIES PROFIT BUILT FROM
THEIR ONLINE SALES AND FROM THE
SALES TAX REBATES.
OFTEN CITIES WILL GIVE THESE
CORPORATIONS MORE THAN HALF OF
THE SALES TAX REVENUES ALLOCATED.
TO THEIR JURISDICTION.
THESE COMPANIES BENEFIT AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE PUBLIC.
AT A TIME WHEN OUR CITIES ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND PUBLIC
PROGRAMS.
COMPANIES ARE SIPHONING BILLIONS
IN TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
THROUGH THESE AGREEMENTS.
FURTHER WHILE THESE DEALS ARE
OFTEN TOUTED FOR CREATING JOBS
AND HAVING SUBSTANTIAL ECONOMIC
BENEFITS.
IN MY VIEW THESE CLAIMS ARE
DUBIOUS.
SOME OF THESE AGREEMENTS DO NOT
REQUIRED THAT THE PROMISED JOBS
OR EVEN CREATED.
AND EVEN WHEN THEY DO HOWEVER
JOBS IN THESE WAREHOUSES.
ARE GRUELING.
LOW WAGE AND IN MANY CASES LACK
BENEFITS.
THE CITY'S NEED REAL JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORKING
FAMILIES NOT A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM. FOR THESE REASONS SB
FIVE THIRTY ONE WOULD PROHIBIT
ANY FUTURE SALES TAX SHARING
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AND PRIVATE CORPORATIONS.
IT HAS NO EFFECT ON ANY EXISTING
DEAL WHEN MAKE THAT CLEAR AGAIN.
WOULD HAVE NO AFFECT ON ANY
EXISTING DEAL.
IT TAKES NO MONEY FROM ANY CITY.
AND IT DOES NOT REDUCE THE SALES
TAX REVENUE THAT ANY CITY CAN
RECEIVE IN THE FUTURE.
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION.
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES AND MANY
OTHERS AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO OPEN IT UP FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
PETER GROW THE FLOOR IS YOURS
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I'D.
LIKE TO JUST TELL MY COLLEAGUES
AT YOU KNOW I I REALLY
APPRECIATE LIKE THE INTENT OF
WHAT YOUR BILL DOES.
BUT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHEN
YOU LOOK AT OUR ECONOMICS IT
ECONOMICS THAT WE HAVE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THERE'S A HUGE
DISPARITY FROM THE COASTAL LINES.
AND WHAT WE HAVE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WITH MY COLLEAGUE THAT I
SHARE KERN AND TULARE WITH BUT
WHAT WE DO HAVE IS AN ASSET IS
LAND.
LAND SOMETHING MANY OF YOU DON'T
HAVE IN YOUR DISTRICTS WHERE
THESE HUGE MASSIVE WAREHOUSES OR
BUILDINGS CAN BE.
PLACED AND TO TAKE THIS ECONOMIC
ADVANTAGE AWAY FROM US IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHEN WE SUFFER SO
MUCH WITH A LOT OF POLICIES THAT
ARE PASSED THROUGH THIS AND THIS
IS AN ECONOMIC ADVANTAGE FOR US
FOR INSTANCE.
RIGHT IN KERN COUNTY WE WERE
ABLE TO SECURE WITH TAX CREDITS
THE AMAZON FACILITY THAT
PROVIDED A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
CONSTRUCTION JOBS RIGHT BY OUR
AIRPORT -- THAT LED RIGHT TO THE
FREEWAY WHICH GAVE AMAZON A
DELIVERY POINT SO THAT THEY
COULD GET PRODUCTS OUT TO ALL OF
YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND THAT CREATED THOUSANDS OF
JOBS IN OUR DISTRICT -- GOOD
PAYING JOBS THAT WE DESPERATELY
NEED IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY SO
LIKE I SAID I UNDERSTAND -- THE
YOUR YUR COMMENTS AND I
UNDERSTAND THE BILL BUT I WANT
YOU TO THINK ABOUT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN THE RULE AREAS BECAUSE
WE DO HAVE AN ASSET AND IT'S THE
LAND IN THE PLACES TO PUT THESE
FACILITIES.
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE ECONOMIC
GROWTH IN OUR AREAS AS WELL.
WE GET WATER RESTRICTION OIL
RESTRICTION A LOT OF THE THINGS
THAT RESTRICT US FROM EMPLOYING
PEOPLE THAT IN KEEPING THEM
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED AT A REALLY
REALLY GOOD WAGE.
AND THIS IS ONE AVENUE THAT WE
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO KEEP IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU LATER.
MEMBERS ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR SENATOR
MORLOCK GOOD MORNING SIR.
MORNING MR PRESIDENT TED TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO MY POLITICAL
CAREER STARTED BECAUSE I DECIDED
TO POINT OUT.
THE PROBLEMS WITH A MONEY MAKING
SCHEME THAT WAS BEING.
PERPETRATED BY THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE.
OUR TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR HAD
FIGURED OUT A WAY TO BORROW ON
THE SHORT END OF THE YIELD CURVE.
BY FOR YOUR BONDS A LITTLE
FURTHER OUT AND MAKE THE SPREAD.
AND SINCE THAT WAS SO GOOD HE HE
TRIPLE DOWNEY BORROWED THREE
TIMES MORE. TO MAKE THIS
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF MONEY --
FOR THE PARTICIPANTS SOME
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
PARTICIPANTS FROM AROUND THE
STATE IN THE PORTFOLIO THE
ORANGE COUNTY INVESTMENT POOL.
AND WHEN I RAN IT WAS COUNTY
WIDE AND I WOULD BUMP IN THE
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS.
AND THEY WOULD LITERALLY CHEW ME
OUT WHY AM I GOING AFTER THE
GOOSE THAT IS LAYING THE GOLDEN
EGGS IT'S THIS GUY WHO IS
GENERATING ALL THIS EXTRA
INTEREST INCOME THAT'S HELPING
US.
BALANCE OUR BUDGET DURING THE
NINETEEN NINETY RECESSION.
MEMBERS KNOW THAT WE HAVE A LOT
OF BUSINESS THAT WE ARE TAKING
CARE OF AN ACID THE COULD PLEASE
KEEP OUR CONVERSATIONS TO A
MINIMUM.
THERE ARE MORE LOCKED I
APOLOGIZE FOR INTERRUPTING THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
MISTER PRESIDENT YOU CAN
INTERRUPT ME ANYTIME.
YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
SO WHAT NO ONE NO ONE REALLY
LOOKED INSIDE THE BLACK BOX NO
ONE SAID WHAT'S HE DOING HE WAS
RUNNING A HEDGE FUND HE WAS
RECALLED THE CARRY TRADE TODAY
AND WHEN INTEREST RATES ARE
RISING ON THE SHORT END OF THE
YIELD CURVE WHICH ARE DOING.
RISE WE SPEAK YOU GET OUT OF HIS
BUSINESS AND HE DID NOT THIS
ENGAGE.
SO WITH THAT THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE IMPLODED WE LOST ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
BECAUSE THE PARTS OF THE SCHEME
STARTED TO MOVE IN THE WRONG.
DIRECTION AND THE COLLATERAL
CALLS ARE MADE IN AN ORANGE
COUNTY WATCHED A BOATLOAD.
OF MONEY COLLEAGUES I'VE SEEN
MORE SCHEMES IN MY TIME NOW THE
PUBLIC SECTOR -- REDEVELOPMENT.
YOU KNOW IF A IF IF WE CAN
CONSIDER A SMALL PART OF OUR
CITIES BLIGHTED THEM.
AND THAT HELPS WITH A TAX
INCREMENTAL A REVENUE TO THE
CITY THEN WHY DON'T WE DECLARE
THE WHOLE CITY BLIGHTED.
ONLY A TWO CITIES IN ORANGE
COUNTY THAT DID JUST THAT AND
NOW THEY'RE STRUGGLING AFTER
REDEVELOPMENT WAS REMOVED.
ANOTHER INTERESTING SCHEME WAS
INTEREST RATE SWAPS IF YOU CAN
BORROW MONEY AND USE THE SHORT
END OF THE YIELD CURVE AND GET A
REAL LOW RATE FOR A PORTION OF
THE DEAL WHY DON'T YOU DO IT FOR
THE WHOLE DEAL.
WELL THAT WORKED OUT GREAT YOUR
HERO UNTIL THE SHORT END OF THE
YIELD CURVE WENT UP IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WE WE HAD
ANOTHER COUNTY GO BANKRUPT OVER
THAT IDEA BECAUSE THEY WENT AND
BORROWED FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
BIRMINGHAM -- ALABAMA AND SO
THEY FILED.
THEN THE LARGEST BANKRUPTCY
FILING CHAPTER NINE BUMPED
ORANGE COUNTY OUT OF FIRST PLACE.
SO THERE'S ALL THESE INTERESTING
IDEAL IDEAS AND SO THESE
SALESMAN COME INTO TOWN TO GIVE
GIVE THESE GREAT.
OPPORTUNITIES AND NOW WILL.
WE HAVE STRUCTURE DEALS TO BUILD
WAREHOUSES IN UNIQUE AREAS AND
THEY GET ALL THE SALES TAXES
IT'S BEING SUCKED OUT.
OF OTHER AREAS THIS IS A SCHEME
AND IT'S NOT GOING TO LAST VERY
LONG.
BECAUSE YOU JUST THE ONE BALLOT
MEASURE OR YOU NEED ONE BILL OUT
OF THIS BUILDING AND YOU CAN
STOP THIS.
AND THOSE CITIES WILL FEEL THE
PAIN BUT IT THEY WILL BE.
PART OF A LONG SUCCESSION OF
CITIES THAT BELL FOR INTERESTING
SCHEME AND THE AND THE PARTIES
THAT ARE PROPOSING THESE SCHEMES
ARE MAKING UP A BOATLOAD OF
MONEY.
IN FEES.
THEY'LL BE HAPPY UNTIL SOMEONE
REALIZES THAT THEY'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN SOLD A BILL OF GOODS.
AND SO THIS BILL IS RIGHTEOUS
THIS BILL IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO IT'S SAYING.
STOP THIS NONSENSE NOW NO MORE
GOING FORWARD BECAUSE YOU ARE
HEADED FOR A TRAIN WRECK I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL.
COLLEAGUES AND STOP THE NONSENSE
BEFORE IT GETS WORSE I ENCOURAGE
AN AYE VOTE ON SB FIVE THREE ONE
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER MORLOCK.
VERY GRATEFUL MEMBERS.
YOU'RE GONNA GO TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER AND ENDED SENATOR SKINNER.
MR MAJORITY LEADER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE -- WE HAVE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WHEN THE VOTERS
MADE A CHOICE. TO A LIMIT
PROPERTY TAXES IN THE MANNER
THEY DID.
HAVE COME UP WITH A SERIES OF
MECHANISMS SOME OF WHICH YOU'VE
WORKED SOME OF WHICH HAVEN'T.
IT'S RESULTED IN WHAT WE WHAT
WAS NO OFTEN KNOWN IN THE IN THE
IN THE PARLANCE IS FISCAL IS
ATION OF LAND USE AND I WOULD
SUGGEST.
THAT AS WE DEBATE THIS HOUSING
ISSUE AND WE LOOK AT THE VARIOUS
CAUSES THIS RELOCATION OF
BRADLEY BURNS MONEY INTO THESE
KINDS OF PROJECTS WHERE WE CAN
INCENTIVIZE THESE FOLKS.
THESE BIG BUSINESSES TO DO THIS
STUFF FOR BIG BOX RETAIL OUTSIDE
OF BIG CITIES AN AUTO MALLS IN
THE LIKE HAS CAUSED A GREAT DEAL
OF THE CONSEQUENCES BECAUSE
CITIES HAVE NOT BEEN INCENTIVIZE.
THE BILL THE HOUSING AND YET
WHEN THE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
FACTORS IT'S ONE OF THE
UNDERLYING CIRCUMSTANCES SO I
SUPPORT THIS BILL I JOIN WITH
THE AUTHOR IN THIS BILL I DO
KNOW AND I THINK THAT THE POINTS
MADE BY THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
ARE CORRECT IN THE SENSE THAT
THERE'S SOME LEVEL OF HARDSHIP.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT BUT THERE
ARE BETTER WAYS TO MAKE THE FIX
THERE ARE BETTER WAYS WE NOW
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES OWNS WHERE WE
CAN USE INCOME TAX FROM
TAXPAYERS.
THERE'S A NUMBER OF NEW THINGS
ON THE SHELVES THAT WILL PROVIDE
INCENTIVES THAT DON'T HAVE THE
DOWNTURN THAT THIS IS DONE BY
PROMOTING BIG BOX RETAIL
PARTICULARLY OUT OF LARGE CITIES.
YOU KNOW AND AND THAT IT'S
CREATED THIS PROBLEM WITH FISCAL
IS ATION OF LAND USE WE HAVE TO
TRY TO WORK ON THIS FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS I THINK THIS IS A
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD.
ASK YOUR EYE BELOW THANK YOU AS
MAJORITY LEADER WE NOW LIKE TO
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR
SKINNER GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL ALSO AND I APPRECIATE
THAT.
MANY OF OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM THE CURRENT
RULES AND I TWO THREE SHE WHY A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WOULD PURSUE
THAT BECAUSE WE'RE ALL THE WAY
OUR TAX STRUCTURE IS.
ALL OVER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
HAVING TO COMPETE FOR REVENUE.
NOW.
I STAND HERE THOUGH AND SAY WE
NEED TO DEFEND ALL OF OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
I WAS THE AUTHOR OF THE
LEGISLATION.
DURING THE RECESSION.
THAT FIRST.
BROKE THE THAT ARE.
PRACTICE FIRE INTERNET RETAILERS
OF BASICALLY DENYING THE STATE
IN OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
SALES TAX REVENUE.
AND WHAT WAS HAPPENING SO LET'S
JUST TALK AMAZON FOR MINUTE.
AMAZON'S.
BUSINESS MODEL WAS BASED ON
GIVING YOU AN AYE THE PERCEPTION
THAT WE COULD BUY IT CHEAPER
FROM THEM BECAUSE WE DIDN'T PAY
SALES TAX NOW UNDER CALIFORNIA
LAW WE STILL OWE THAT SALES TAX.
BUT THAT LEFT OUR FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD INTO IT LEFT THEM HAVING
TO COLLECT FROM EACH OF US
INDIVIDUALLY VERY INEFFICIENT
AND BASICALLY LEFT A LOT OF
MONEY ON THE TABLE.
SO COURSE DURING THE RECESSION
THERE ARE LOTS OF FACTORS BUT WE
SAW OUR BRICK AND MORTAR BILL.
BUSINESSES UP AND DOWN THE STATE
ARE DOWNTOWNS COLLAPSING AS
RETAILERS CLOSED AND INTERNET
SALES GREW.
TODAY WE NOW INTERNET SALES
ACROSS THE US HAVE NOW.
REACHED A HIGHER NUMBER THAN
BURKE AND MORTAR SO WHILE THIS
BILL IS NOT GOING TO SAVE ALL
BRICK AND MORTAR IT LEAST ALLOWS
A MORE LEVEL PLAYING FIELD.
AND IT ALLOWS EVERY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO GET SOME SHEER OF
THOSE PURCHASES THANK YOU WHEN I
MAKE VERSES ALLOWING JUST A FEW
LOCAL OVERNMENTS. TO IN A WAY
GIVE AWAY MONEY THAT SHOULD GO
TO THE STATE AND SHOULD GO TO
ALL OF US GIVE AWAY JUST SO THEY
CAN CONSOLIDATE.
IN YES GET REVENUE THEMSELVES
BUT WE LOSE WE EAT THE WHOLE
STATE AND EVERY CITY IN THE
ENTIRE STATE COFFERS LOSE AS A
RESULT OF THE DEAL.
SO LET'S GO BACK TO FAIRNESS TO
PROTECTING WHATEVER BURKE AND
MORTARS WE HAVE LEFT.
AND THIS DOES NOT UNDO THE DEAL
SO FAR IF I WERE CARRYING THE
BILL I MIGHT ADD I TRIED TO UNDO
THE DEALS BUT WHATEVER IT
DOESN'T SO THOSE VIEW.
THOSE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT
HAVE THEM OR NOT HURT AND I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER MEMBERS
WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR.
LAST CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEE NINE WE'D LIKE TO
TURN OVER TO CENTER GLAZER FOR
CLOSING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR THE
SPIRITED DIED DEBATE THIS
MORNING. TO THE SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD I'M I'M SENSITIVE TO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE
IMPACT THIS TYPE OF LEGISLATION
COULD HAVE -- I WOULD SAY THIS
THAT THOSE CITY STILL HAVE ALL
THE OTHER -- TAXES THAT ARE
COLLECTED THAT THEY CAN UTILIZE
TO INCENTIVIZE OF THAT THAT'S
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO THEY HAVE
PROPERTY TAXES THE OF THE SALES
TAXES THAT THEY COLLECT.
THE ONLY THING IT SAYS IN THIS
BILL IS YOU CAN'T HAVE A NEW
DEAL THE TAKE SALES TAXES FROM
ALL OF OUR OTHER CITIES.
AS AN INCENTIVE TO LOCATE THERE
AND I I I I DID NOT TRYING THIS
LEGISLATION TO UNRAVEL THOSE
DEALS THAT HAVE OCCURRED ALREADY
I AM INTERESTED IN TRYING TO DO
THAT AND THAT'S AS SENSITIVE WAY.
TO BALANCE THE ISSUES THAT YOU
RAISE BUT I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU'VE RAISED ON
THE FLOOR.
THE SENATOR FROM COSTA MESA.
IT IS TRUE THAT THERE IS A LOT
OF SCHEMES THAT HAVE BEEN PUT IN
PLACE -- BY PROFITEERS --
BLOOMBERG NEWS JUST AT A BIG
STORY ON THE PROFITEERS TO
DIFFUSE BRADLEY BURNS TO
MANIPULATE.
ARRANGEMENTS WITH CITIES AND
TAKEN PROFITS FOR THEMSELVES AND
WAS A GREAT EXPOSES A AND I'M
CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN TRYING
TO STOP THAT CURTAIL AND I THINK
THIS LEGISLATION DOES.
DO THAT GOING FORWARD.
I TO THE SENATOR FROM THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY GREAT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS
WHOLE AREA OF TAX REFORM -- YOU
BRING UP AN IMPORTANT POINT
ABOUT FAIRNESS AND INCENTIVES
AND HAVING THEM RIGHT SIDED.
AND CERTAINLY THIS BILL.
HELPS LEAD IN THAT DIRECTION
ALTHOUGH I KNOW WE HAVE A LOT
MORE WORK TO DO AND UNDER YOUR
LEADERSHIP WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT.
AND THE SENATOR FROM BERKELEY I
I APPRECIATE HER HISTORY ON TAX
REFORM.
AND CERTAINLY AT THE MAIN POINT
THAT YOU MADE WHICH IS THAT OUR
TAX REFORM HAS TO BENEFIT ALL OF
OUR CITIES.
AND NOT NOT ALLOW THIS WINNERS
AND LOSERS TO BE PICKED.
PICKED ON PICKED APART -- TO
WHAT -- IN IN A WAY THAT THAT
HURTS -- MANY OF OUR PUBLIC
SERVICES THAT ARE CITIES ARE
OBLIGATED TO ON TO PERFORM.
SO MEMBERS IN CLOSING LET ME SAY
THAT.
THIS MEASURE -- TRIES TO STOP
THE DAMAGE GOING FORWARD -- IT'S
TO PREVENT CORPORATIONS FOR
MANIPULATING OUR TAX CODE WHICH
ARE DOING TODAY.
ON THIS THE TERM OF POINT OF
SALE.
I AM TRYING TO RIGHT SIZE AT
LEAST GOING FORWARD THE
MANIPULATION OF OUR TAX.
CODE AND WITH THAT MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE DEBATE AND I
APPRECIATE AN AYE VOTE TODAY MR
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN HI FI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO BELL.
HI PORGES BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
HI JANE [inaudible]
HI DODD [inaudible]
THEY'RE ALSO.
BY GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER HI HI GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
NO.
JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BUY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
BY MORNING THANK YOU TONY BYE
MORE LOCK.
HI WE HAVE THE OF THE RAIL TO DO.
YEAH NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN HI HI PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
BY WHAT COUNTY BY WINNER
[inaudible]
HI WILK -- NO.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE ON THE FLOOR.
AND THEY WERE GONNA CALL THE
VOTE.
MISTER SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE S. MEMBERS WERE
JUST.
BRADFORD [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
ROTH.
HI TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS.
EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATORS WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO TALK ABOUT SOME HOUSEKEEPING
HERE AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
REST OF OUR MORNING.
WE HAVE AS MOST OF YOU KNOW AND
IMPORTANT APPROPRIATIONS MEETING
TODAY.
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL NEED
TO REPORT TO THE HEARING ROOM
SHORTLY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'D LIKE TO
TAKE TO ADDITIONAL ITEMS UP.
UNDER SENATE THIRD READING.
THAT WOULD BE FILE ITEM THIRTY
TWO S. C. R. FORTY SEVEN AN FILE
ITEM.
SIXTY NINE S. C. R..
FORTY EIGHT AFTER THAT WE'LL
NEED TO ADVANCE WITH OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR IN OUR SPECIAL CONSENT.
GO TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
AND ADJOURNMENTS.
MEMBERS WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE WITH THEIR FIRST
OF TWO FINAL ITEMS FOR THE DAY.
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO CENTER
RUBIO IS PREPARED TO PRESENT.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE TO SMALL
BUSINESS MONTH THEN RUBIO GOOD
MORNING THE FLOOR IS YOURS A
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
I RISE TO INTRODUCE F. C. R.
FORTY SEVEN WHICH DECLARES MAY
TWENTY NINETEEN AS CALIFORNIA
SMALL.
BUSINESS MONTH AND PROMOTES THE
IMPORTANCE OF BUSINESSES IN OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY SMALL BUSINESSES.
ARE THE ECONOMIC ENGINE.
IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES THEY
GENERATE ABOUT HALF OF ALL JOBS
IN CALIFORNIA ALLOWING
ENTREPRENEURS FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS TO EARN A LIVING AND
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR GOLDEN STATE.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THERE WERE
OVER THREE POINT NINE MILLION.
SMALL BUSINESSES AND THE STATE
REPRESENTING AN OVERWHELMING
SHARE OF CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE
BY EMPLOYING MORE THAN SEVEN
MILLION PEOPLE.
AND OF THE SEVENTY THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SMALL
FIRMS THAT EXPORTED GOODS FROM
CALIFORNIA.
THEY GENERATED 43% OF THE STATE
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO BILLION
IN TOTAL EXPORTS.
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT AS WELL
THAT WITHIN THE SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY A GROWING NUMBER OF
THESE COMPANIES ARE STARTED AT
OWNED BY WOMEN.
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND IMMIGRANTS
AND IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT ONE POINT SIX
MILLION SMALL BUSINESSES WERE
MINORITY OWNED.
LET'S REAFFIRM OUR COMMITMENT TO
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES
WHICH ENHANCE CALIFORNIANS WHO
HUMAN CAPITAL.
EXPAND JOB OPPORTUNITIES AND
INCREASE OUR COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE IN THE GLOBAL
MARKETPLACE I WANT TO ALSO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
BEING A JOINT AUTHORS ON THIS
RESOLUTION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR SPEAKING OF
THAT JOINT AUTHORED FROM SAN
DIEGO WOULD LIKE TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO MATTER PROTEIN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND I
WANNA ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BALDWIN PARK
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
AND RECOGNIZING MAY AS SMALL
BUSINESS MONTH.
YOU KNOW I'VE SAID IT.
A NUMBER OF TIMES AND YOU'RE
GONNA HEAR ME SAY IT A LOT MORE.
YOU HEARD THE NUMBERS I THINK WE
CAN HEAR THOSE NUMBERS AND JUST
GO AHA AHA AHA. SIX THIRTY THIS
MORNING I WAS WITH A SMALL
BUSINESS -- MY PERSONAL TRAINER
IS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND I
WAS THERE AT SIX THIRTY THIS
MORNING -- TODAY I KNOW THAT MY
INCREDIBLY WONDERFUL PET HALEY
WHO'S FIFTEEN WE'LL BE SEEING
OUR VETERINARIAN.
THAT PERSON IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO ME TODAY BECAUSE HI
HAILEY SEES HER VETERINARIAN
QUITE OFTEN.
HI THERE'S NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT TO ME.
MY NAILS LOOK FABULOUS THAT'S
BECAUSE MY SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
IN MISSION HILLS IN SAN DIEGO.
DID MY NAILS ON SUNDAY.
MY CAR MECHANIC -- MY MASSAGE
THERAPIST.
MY GARDENER.
AW I CANNOT GET THROUGH THE DAY
I CANNOT GET THROUGH THE WEEK.
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT OF A SMALL
BUSINESS SO I WANT TO BRING IT
HOME AND ADD TO THOSE NUMBERS.
I WOULDN'T BE HERE WITHOUT MY
SPOUSE BEING A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER BECAUSE SHE ACTUALLY IS
VERY SUCCESSFUL AND HER BUSINESS
THANK GOODNESS -- SO I WANT
PEOPLE TO STOP AND THINK AND AND
THINK ABOUT THE DATA AND THE
NUMBERS IN A WAY THAT IS
MEANINGFUL TO US.
MY GLASSES MIGHT AYE DOCTOR IS A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER MY DENTIST
IS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER I HAVE
A GREAT HEALTH PLAN I GO TO
KAISER.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO PEOPLE I
HAVE KNOWN FOR TWENTY AND THERE
ARE YOU KNOW I'M OLDER.
I'VE HAD MY EYE DOCTOR FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS I'VE HAD MY
DENTIST.
FOR THIRTY AND SO I DON'T LIKE
CHANGE I LIKE TO SUPPORT PEOPLE.
WHO ARE REALLY SUSTAIN ME AND
KEEP ME CAPABLE OF DOING THE
WORK I DO HERE EVERY DAY AND I
COULDN'T DO IT WITHOUT THEM?
AND SO MAY IS SMALL BUSINESS
MONTH BUT WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
THAT INTO JUNE AND I HOPE THAT
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE HAD A CHANCE
TO MEET WITH THE INCOMPARABLE
BETTY JO TO COLLATE.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION MS MITCHELL
THANK YOU.
ANYONE THAT'S EVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY -- THAT WOMAN IS
SERIOUS AND SHE WILL BRING IN A
NUMBER OF SMALL BUSINESSES TO
YOUR DISTRICT OFFICE. TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT ALL OF THE
DIFFICULT ISSUES WE FACE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WE TRY TO BALANCE
THINGS AND SUPPORT OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
AND SO I HOPE THAT ON WEDNESDAY
JUNE NINETEENTH WE'VE ALSO LIKED
IT OUR BUSINESSES TO RECOGNIZING
GIVE THEM THAT. FIVE TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF GREAT FAME HERE IN
THEIR STATE CAPITOL BECAUSE I
WILL BE THERE -- IN SUPPORT AND
I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
RESOLUTION AND OUT HOW
MEANINGFUL IT IS TO US IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OUR ECONOMY
WOULD NOT BE THE FIFTH LARGEST
IN THE WORLD -- WITHOUT THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES WE CAN THANK
OUR CORPORATIONS AND AND LARGE
BUSINESSES BECAUSE EVERY NOW AND
THEN I GOT TO CLICK A BUTTON AND
GET SOMETHING TO BE QUICKLY.
BECAUSE I HAVE NOT PLANNED IN
ADVANCE.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE REAL
THE REAL RUBBER MEETS THE ROAD I
COULDN'T LIVE EVERY SINGLE DAY
WITHOUT THOSE PEOPLE MAKING MY
LIFE BETTER SO THANK YOU -- FOR
CELEBRATING SMALL BUSINESS MONTH --
LET'S TAKE IT INTO JUNE AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING EVERYBODY
ON JUNE NINETEENTH OVER AT THE
CONVENTION CENTER OR THE
SHERATON ACTUALLY SORRY THE
SHERATON AS WE CELEBRATE SMALL
BUSINESS MONTH.
THANK YOU PER TO MACHEN'S WE NOW
LIKE TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR STONE.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
GOOD MORNING MR PRESIDENT AND A
AND COLLEAGUES I WANT TO APPLAUD
THE SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD
AND I WANT TO THANK THE PRO TEM
FOR HER.
HER WONDERFUL REMARKS -- YOU
KNOW I BEEN A SMALL BUSINESSMAN
NOW IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE FOR
THIRTY SIX YEARS -- OWNED AND
OPERATED. SIX PHARMACIES -- A
RESPIRATORY COMPANY A PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT COMPANY [inaudible]
AND I WASN'T BORN ON THE RICH
SIDE OF THE TRACKS I WAS BORN IN
A VERY HUMBLE LOW INCOME FAMILY
BLUE COLLAR WORKERS AND FIRST
GUY TO GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE IN
MY FAMILY AND I KNEW I WANTED TO
BE A SOLE PROPRIETOR.
BUT I KNEW THAT I JUST COULDN'T
GO AND FIX RISE A NEW STORE AND
BUY INVENTORY IN OPEN THE
PHARMACY BY MYSELF.
SO I HAD TO WAIT.
FOR BIG BIG BOX STORES THAT TIME
PROBABLY BEFORE MANY OF YOU WERE
BORN ONE CALLED FED MARK ONE
CALLED.
GEMCO.
AND WHEN THEY THE COM BY I
BOTTLE THEIR PHARMACY FIXTURES
AND EQUIPMENT PUT HIM IN STORAGE
AND AND THEN THE SMALL TOWN OF
TEMECULA NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
FIFTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE.
I WANTED TO OPEN.
MY FIRST OF SIX PHARMACIES.
I WANT TO HAVE THE CHEERS BAR OF
A PHARMACY WE YOUR UNIVERSITIES
NAME THE WALKED IN THE DOOR.
INCLUDING THE LIKES OF JACK
KLUGMAN YOU MAY EMEMBER HIM IN
THE QUINCY SHOW THAT ALSO LIVED
IN TEMECULA I WAS THIS
PHARMACIST AND PROBABLY.
SERVE HIM AND MY OTHER
CONSTITUENTS AND BUILD PRACTICES
UP.
THAT'S THE AMERICAN DREAM THIS --
BEING ABLE.
TO COME FROM HUMBLE BEGINNINGS
AND GO TO SCHOOL.
AND THE GREATEST SCHOOL SYSTEM
IN THE COUNTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND BECOME
[inaudible]
A SUCCESS.
AND I TRY TO PATRONIZE -- SMALL
BUSINESSES LIKE OUR OUR PRO TEM
HAS A EXEMPLIFIED.
OUR DOG GROOMERS -- THE GOING TO
THE SAME PSYCHIATRIST FOR TWENTY
YEARS -- SAME DOCTORS -- BUT I'D
SAY A MENTION THIS I ALSO WANT.
TO PUT A CAUTION OUT THERE.
THAT.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT BILLS
ESPECIALLY BILLS THAT ARE?
ENTERTAINING THE LABOR COMMITTEE
AND AND OTHER BILLS THAT ARE
ADDING MORE REGULATIONS AND MORE
COSTS.
IT IS DISPROPORTIONATELY.
IMPOSED ON SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
I WILL TELL YOU THAT.
THE REGULATIONS GOVERNING COUNT
HOUNDING PHARMACY WHICH I OWN
NOW AND STILL OPERATE.
AB EXPONENTIALLY INCREASED OVER
THE PAST DECADE IN RESPONSE TO
SOME UNFORTUNATE EVENTS THAT
WE'VE SEEN.
ON THE EAST COAST AT A PHARMACY
THAT DIDN'T SET THE GOOD EXAMPLE
SET THE BAD EXAMPLE WHICH CAUSE
KNEE JERK REACTIONS TO HAPPEN
THROUGHOUT.
THE COUNTRY.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE THE BACKBONE OF
OUR ECONOMY NOT ONLY IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND THAT WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO GIVE THEM THE TOOLS TO
SUCCEED.
AND TO ALLOW.
THE DREAM OF OWNING ONE'S
BUSINESS AND GIVING THEM THE
TOOLS TO BE THE ENTREPRENEURS.
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
KNOWN.
FOR SO AGAIN I WANT TO APPLY THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND AND JUST HOPE THAT.
AS WE ENTERTAIN MY DISTILLATION.
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION IN THE
COMING MONTHS THAT WE WILL TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION WHAT THOSE
EFFECTS WOULD BE ON SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
TO SURVIVE.
AND COMPETE NOT ONLY IN A
NATIONAL WORK FORCE BUT IN A
GLOBAL WORK FORCE AND AGAIN
THANK YOU TO THE SENATOR FROM
LOS ANGELES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER STONE
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO CENTER HUESO.
AND THEN TO SENATOR PAN BORN
INCINERATION.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS YOU ARE.
FORTY SEVEN SMALL BUSINESS
CONTINUES TO BE THE BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIA 98%.
OF OUR ECONOMY OR ARE 90% OF THE
BUSINESSES IN OUR STATE OR FEEL
BY SMALL BUSINESS.
AND THEY RATE CONTINUE TO BE THE
SITE WHERE.
INNOVATION IS BORN IN OUR STATE
THIS THE PLACE WHERE.
NEW IDEAS -- COME TO BE.
AND WHERE THE AMERICAN DREAM
BEGINS FOR FOR MANY PEOPLE --
INCLUDING MYSELF I STARTED MY
FIRST BUSINESS WHEN I WAS TWELVE%
YEARS OLD I HAD A LITTLE CAR
WASH BUSINESS ADEQUATE CORNER.
GAS STATION AND AFTER THAT I
STARTED DELIVERING NEWSPAPERS
EVERY MORNING AT FOUR AM THE SAN
DIEGO UNION -- THE I HAD A
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT CUSTOMERS
AT THAT I WOULD GET UP AT FOUR
IN THE MORNING RIDE MY BIKE FROM
MY NEIGHBOR DELIVERING PAPERS.
AND I THOUGHT.
MY MY WHOLE LIFE WOULD BE
RESIDENT AROUND BUSINESS AND IT
JUST -- IS A WONDERFUL THING TO
BE YOUR OWN BOSS EVERYDAY.
BUT YOU KNOW THE THE BIGGEST
THING FACING THE BIGGEST THREAT
FACING BUT AS BUSINESS ON OUR
STATE CONTINUES TO BE MONOPOLIES.
IT CONTINUES TO BE OF A TAX
BREAKS FOR THE CORPORATIONS THAT
ARE NOT GIVEN TO SMALL BUSINESS
IT CONTINUES TO BE.
REGULATIONS THAT FAVOR LARGER.
MORE WELL FUNDED CORPORATIONS
AND OVER OVER SMALL BUSINESS AND
THAT'S I THINK THE BIGGEST
THREAT AS A AS A BUSINESS OWNER --
IN CALIFORNIA FOR A FOR TWENTY
YEARS.
I CAN TELL YOU THE BIGGEST
THREAT.
IT IS IS IT'S NOT REGULATION
REGULATION OFTEN IS IS.
ENCOURAGED BY BUSINESSES CENTER
TOOK.
CREATE A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD.
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD SO
EVERYBODY COULD KEEP COMPETE
EQUAL.
EQUALLY TO HAVE AN EQUAL ACCESS
TO THE AMERICAN DREAM BUT IF YOU
START FAVOR IN.
THE BIG COMPANIES IF YOU START
PROVIDING THEM WITH WITH OF WITH
REGULATIONS GIVE THEM.
PREFERENCE OVER.
OF DOMINATING THE THE ECONOMIC.
ENVIRONMENT.
THAT'S WHAT'S GONNA KILL SMALL
BUSINESS IN OUR STATE.
SO AS WE EVOLVE AS WE CELEBRATE
ALL THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
LET'S KEEP THAT IN MIND.
BUT ALSO CONTINUE TO SEND THAT
MESSAGE TO PEOPLE THAT WE
CALIFORNIA IS THE NUMBER ONE
ECONOMY IN THE NATION.
BECAUSE WHAT WE ARE THAT
ENVIRONMENT FOR INNOVATION
WITHOUT IT WE ARE THAT
ENVIRONMENT. FOR INVESTMENT. 70%
OF OF ALL THE OF NEW.
INVESTMENT CAPITAL THAT IS SPENT.
IN AMERICA OF OF OF OF A 100% OF
ALL START UP CAPITAL FUNDS 70%
COMES TO CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S A REASON WHY THAT IS.
THERE'S A REASON WHY WE DOMINATE
THE INVESTMENT -- OF OF THE THE
INTEREST OF THE INVESTMENT
COMMUNITY BECAUSE CALIFORNIA.
CONTINUES TO BE THE PLACE.
WHERE BUSINESS START UPS?
WANT TO WHERE WHERE BUSINESSES
WANT TO BEGIN.
THIS IS THE PLACE I WANT TO BE
LOCATED OVER OVERWHELMINGLY THIS
IS A PLACE WE CONTINUE
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO BE THE
INCUBATOR.
THE BUSINESS INCUBATOR OF
AMERICA AND WE HAVE.
TO BE MINDFUL OF THAT AND WE
HAVE TO PROTECT THAT WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE. TO SUPPORT POLICIES
THAT -- MAKE THAT HAPPEN FOR OUR
STATE THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOONER HUESO
MEMBERS VETERAN FLORIDA SENATOR
PAN.
I THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH --
PRESIDENT AND I WANT TO THANK MY
GOOD FRIENDS FROM BALDWIN PARK
IN SAN DIEGO FOR BRING THIS
RESOLUTION FORD STAND STRONG
SUPPORT -- IT DO YOU HAVE TO
FEEL COMPELLED SPEAK BECAUSE MY
WIFE IS A WOMAN OF COLOR HAS AN
IMMIGRANTS WHO START A SMALL
BUSINESS AND SHE STILL RUNS THAT --
BUSINESS TODAY AND SHE'S -- AND
I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES OF TRYING TO START
THAT BUSINESS -- NOW FRANKLY
YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE THE OWNER OF
A SMALL BUSINESS YOU'RE STARTING
A SMALL BUSINESS YEAR LAST ONE
TO GET PAID.
RIGHT YOU GOT TO PAY YOUR RENT
YOU GOT PAID UNTIL IT EASY PAY
YOUR EMPLOYEES.
AND SOMETIMES YOU'RE BEGINNING
JOAN POCKET IN THE VERY
BEGINNING IN ORDER TO MAKE.
ENDS MEET SO THAT YOUR BUSINESS
CAN CONTINUE AND CLEARLY YOU
ALSO INTERACT WITH ALL OF YOUR
EMPLOYEES AS WELL.
AND HAVE TO WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THEM AND THEIR YOUR PART
YOUR EXTENDED FAMILY AND SO I
THINK WE NEED TO WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT AS SMALL BUSINESS
I THINK I THINK THAT AGAIN WE
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THE VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE SMALL BUSINESS
PLATE.
AS AN ECONOMIC ENGINE BUT ALSO
CREATION OF OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE
IS THAT THE VERY GROUPS.
TO LOOK IS IT STARTING SMALL
BUSINESSES AND CERTAINLY THAT
ENTREPRENEURS.
WHAT DROVE THEM BUT OFTENTIMES
OPPORTUNITIES ARE NOT
NECESSARILY EQUALLY THERE FOR
THEM IN LARGE ORGANIZATIONS AND
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE MANY -- YEAH
AND YOU SEE WOMEN YOU SEE PEOPLE
COLOR IS HIS IMMIGRANTS STARTING
A BUSINESS IS I DO WANT TO JUST
MENTION -- THAT ACTUALLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE TAKEN IMPORTANT
STEPS TO ACTUALLY ALLOW AND
PERMIT PEOPLE TO BE MORE
ENTREPRENEURS HERE BECAUSE WE
PASSED COVERED CALIFORNIA.
AND ACTUALLY THERE IS DATA SHOW
THAT BY ACTUALLY ARE IN OUR
EMBRACE OF THE ACA INCLUDING THE
INDIVIDUAL STABILIZING THE
INDIVIDUAL INSURANCE MARKET
WE'VE HELPED PEOPLE GET OUT OF
WHAT'S CALLED JOB LOCK.
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T ABLE IF YOU
HAVE A CHRONIC CONDITION.
YOU CAN'T GO BY INSURANCE AND
INDIVIDUAL MARKET BECAUSE THE
PRE EXISTING CONDITION
AFFORDABLE INSURANCE AND GO OFF
AND PURSUE YOUR DREAMS AS AN
ENTREPRENEUR.
AND FACT WE HAVE SEEN A
NOTICEABLE TAKE UPWARDS AND
PEOPLE WILLING TO BE ABLE TO
START THEIR OWN BUSINESSES
BECAUSE OF COVERED CALIFORNIA.
SO I SHOULD MAKE NOTE THAT WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT THINGS WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO THINK ABOUT
REGULATIONS AND LAWS AND HOW DO
WE MAKE IT EASIER FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES BECAUSE I KNOW SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS WANT TO DO THE
RIGHT THING.
I KNOW THEY WANT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING THEY OFTEN THOSE ARE
CLARITY FROM US YOU KNOW THEY
WANT CLEAN AIR CLEAN WATER DAY
WHAT THEIR WORK IS TO BE TAKEN
CARE OF THEY WANT CLEARLY FROM
US HOW TO DO IT.
BUT THEY ALSO NEED THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE THINGS LIKE
COVERED CALIFORNIA TO ALLOW THEM
TO HAVE THAT INDEPENDENCE THAT
FREEDOM. TO BE ABLE TO PURSUE
THEIR ENTREPRENEURIAL DREAMS I
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER AND MEMBERS
WITH A TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR AWESOME.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU -- THE
PRESIDENT -- I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT AND THANK SENATOR --
FROM BALDWIN PARK ON THE ISSUE
OF SMALL BUSINESSES SMALL
BUSINESSES AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID
ALSO ARE IN POOR WAY FOR
IMMIGRANTS TO INTEGRATE INTO THE
ECONOMY.
AND MANY MANY COMMUNITIES HAVE
MAINTAINED THEIR VIBRANCY
BECAUSE OF IMMIGRANTS OPENING
AND STARTING AND MAINTAINING
SMALL BUSINESSES IN PARTICULAR I
WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES -- THAT DO GIVE
THE KINDS OF WAGES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT FOR FAMILIES TO
SUSTAIN THEMSELVES -- LIKE
LANGER IS WORLD FAMOUS LET WORLD
FAMOUS LANGER'S DELICATESSEN UP
TO LEAVE THE ORIGINAL IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES THE PANTRY.
THOSE ARE JUST THREE OF THE MANY
SMALL BUSINESSES RESTAURANTS
THAT HAVE SUSTAINED OUR
COMMUNITIES AGAINST MANY MANY
ODDS.
AND AT THE SAME TIME A PROVIDED
GOOD FAMILY WAGES FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES SO.
WE SHOULD EQUATE -- SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ENCOURAGE AND
HELP THEM TO ALSO BE IN A
POSITION TO PAY THOSE KINDS OF
WAGES THAT REALLY LIFT AND
DEFEND AND PROTECT -- GOOD
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR JACKSON
GOOD MORNING CENTER JACKSON YES
THANK YOU -- MISS PRESENT
COLLEGE I WANT TO STAND UP AND
AND AGAIN THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BALDWIN.
OF PARK.
AS WELL AS OUR PRO TEM FOR
SHARING WITH US.
WHAT COMPRISES HER DAILY ROUTE --
OR WEEKLY ROUTINE -- SO THAT I
CAN TRY TO EMULATE THAT.
ALTHOUGH THE SIX THIRTY THE
MORNINGS A LITTLE EARLY -- FOR
SOME OF US.
BUT I WANT TO FOCUS IF I MAY ON
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES --
BECAUSE WE ARE FINDING NOW THAT --
BETWEEN -- IN A STUDY BY
AMERICAN EXPRESS FOUND THAT BE
FROM NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE NUMBER OF
SMALL BUSINESSES.
GREW BY 44% BUT THE NUMBER OF
WOMEN OWNED SMALL BUSINESSES
GREW BY A HUNDRED AND 14% A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN OF
COURSE -- IN CALIFORNIA AS ONE
MIGHT EXPECT -- THE OUR STATE'S
REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES IS 15% HIGHER THAN
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE NEW
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES OPEN IN
CALIFORNIA EVERY DAY.
AND THE BIGGEST HURDLE THAT BOTH.
OF THE SMALL BUSINESSES RUN BY
MEN AND WOMEN FACE IS FINANCING.
AND THAT WOMEN HAVE OF A GREATER
OBSTACLES IN OBTAINING THAT
FINANCING SO AS WE LOOK -- TO
FOCUS ON SMALL BUSINESSES AND
ALL OF THE CLAIMS ABOUT WHAT
CAUSES PROBLEMS AND WHAT HAVE
YOU.
IT'S THAT INITIAL START UP
FUNDING.
AND AS WOMEN WANT THAT
FLEXIBILITY IN OWNING THEIR OWN
BUSINESSES THE NEEDS TO
ACCOMMODATE AND BALANCE CHILD
CARE.
OF THE FAMILY NEEDS AND THE
DESIRE AND THE NEED TO OBTAIN I
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY ARISE WE
WILL CONTINUE TO SEE MORE AND
MORE WOMEN STEPPING INTO THE
ENTREPRENEURIAL WORLD.
AND IT IS A VERY EXCITING TO
HEAR OF THE NUMBER OF WOMEN WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING IN THAT WRLD
LET'S HOPE THEY CONTINUE TO HAVE.
THE ABILITY IN THE FLEXIBILITY
DECISION MAKING TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE KEEPING CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND LIVING THE GRAY CALIFORNIA
DREAM.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD URGE YOUR
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
SENATORS WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
CENTER RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
THINK ON MY COLLEAGUES FOR
STANDING UP IN SUPPORT OF S. C.
R..
FORTY SEVEN IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT -- WITH KNOWLEDGE ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES AND I WILL
CLOSE WITH THIS IF I MAY SHARE
WHEN I WAS A LOCAL COUNCIL
MEMBER I WAS 1100% CERTAIN.
THAT ARE SMALL BUSINESSES
ALLOWED US TO EXPAND OUR
PRORAMS.
CHILD STEP CITY AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS OUR SENIORS HAVE PLACES
TO GO EVERY DAY BECAUSE OF THEIR
TAX REVENUE.
AND IN ADDITION THEY ALLOWED US
TO TAKE CARE OF OUR S. YEAH YOU
FAMILY OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
FAMILIES AND SO WITH THAT I JUST
WANT TO BE MINDFUL AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WE NEED.
TO ALWAYS KEEP THEM IN MIND
THEY'RE NOT ALWAYS BIG BABIES
THEY CAN BE IN ALL SMALL BUT
THEY'RE VERY MIGHTY IN OUR
COMMUNITY SO WITH THAT I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
MISTER SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES.
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROWTH
[inaudible]
HI HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TADO.
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
BY MORE LACKEY.
I'M A REAL.
AYE NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROSS [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
HI NUMBER.
BY WHY CASSIE.
I WIENER.
AYE WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SENATORS ARE GONNA CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL MEASURE
RIGHT AFTER THIS.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT A CERTAIN
MEMBERS MISTER SECRETARY.
BURGESS.
JONES.
HI MITCHELL HI HI.
I THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS.
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE LIKE TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR TO SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I HAVE SOME VERY SPECIAL
GUESTS IN THE GALLERY TODAY I
WANTED.
TO INTERRUPT OUR COURSE A
BUSINESS HERE IN SESSION TO
RECOGNIZE THE POINT DUME
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL FOURTH GRADE
CLASS THEY WENT THROUGH THE
WALLS THE FIRE.
AND IT TORE THROUGH OUR BACKYARD
THIS IS THE LITTLE STRETCH OF
APART A CALIFORNIA I GREW UP IN.
RIGHT DOWN THE STREET FROM --
THE HOUSE I LIVED IN FOR MY
WHOLE LIFE AND I KNOW THEY'VE
BEEN THROUGH A LOT BUT THEY'RE
INCREDIBLE LEADERS AMONGST US
AND I APPRECIATE YOU ALL BEING
UP HERE TO WATCH HOW DEMOCRACY
WORKS AND FOR BEING RESILIENT.
AND FOR BEING -- AMAZING AND
HOPEFUL YOUNG PEOPLE SO PLEASE
RECOGNIZE OUR FOURTH GRADE
CLASSROOM POINT DUME ALLEN A TO
SCHOOL.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
SENATORS WE HAVE ONE FINAL ITEM
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING UP ON
OUR DOCKET TODAY.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
SIXTY NINE MISTER SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY EIGHT BY SENATE ARCHULETA
RELATIVE TO NATIONAL MILITARY
APPRECIATION MONTH.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR WELCOME THE
FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN WE HEARD
TODAY ABOUT OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
LET'S NOT FORGET HOW THEY'RE
ABLE TO BE PROTECTED IN.
AND TO EVEN EXIST WITHOUT THE
THE FREEDOMS THAT WE HAVE IN
THIS GREAT COUNTRY.
SO MISTER PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT AS C. R. FORTY EIGHT
DECLARING MAY AS THE NATIONAL
MILITARY APPRECIATION MONTH.
NATIONAL MILITARY APPRECIATION
MONTH BEGAN AS A SIMPLE IDEA. TO
GATHER AMERICA AROUND ITS
MILITARY FAMILIES TO HONOR
REMEMBER RECOGNIZE AND
APPRECIATE.
THOSE WHO SERVE AND HAVE SERVED
ALL WHEN KNOWING ITS HISTORY AND
ITS DANGERS.
NATIONAL MILITARY APPRECIATION
MONTH INCLUDES LOYALTY DAY.
VICTORY IN EUROPE DAY MILITARY
SPOUSE APPRECIATION DAY ARMED
FORCES DAY AND MEMORIAL DAY.
THERE ARE MORE THAN THIRTY MAJOR
DEFENSE INSTALLATIONS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND CORPORATION ALL
MILITARY SERVICES.
MORE THAN DOUBLE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE NETWORK OF
TRAINING AND THE RANGERS.
OUR NATIONAL TREASURE THAT COULD
NOT BE A A REPLICATED OR REPLACE.
EACH OF THESE BASES ARE UNIQUE
IMPORTANT MILITARY VALUE.
AGES MAKING CRITICAL
CONTRIBUTION TO NATIONAL
SECURITY TODAY AND FOR THE
FUTURE.
AND ACCOUNTING FOR OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND ACTIVE DUTY PERSONNEL
NATIONAL GUARD PERSONNEL.
AND THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED RESERVE PERSONNEL
STATIONED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT MONTH HONORS
REMEMBERS RECOGNIZES AND
APPRECIATES ALL MILITARY
PERSONNEL.
WHO HAVE SERVED THROUGHOUT OUR
HISTORY?
ALL WHO NOW SERVED IN UNIFORM
AND THOSE FAMILIES AS WELL AS
THOSE AMERICANS WHO HAVE GIVEN
THEIR LIVES IN THE DEFENSE OF
FREEDOM.
THAT WE ENJOY THE DAY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
MAY IS THE NATIONAL MILITARY
APPRECIATION DAY.
AND FOR THIS REASON I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SENATOR.
CENTERS WE HAD DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
LEADER GROVE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AS
THE FIRST FEMALE VETERAN IT'S
EVER SERVED IN THIS BUILDING I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HONOR ALL VETERANS THOSE THAT
HAVE PASSED IN THOSE THAT ARE
CONTINUING TO SERVE TODAY.
SO I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR AND I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU THIS NEXT
MONTH TO PARTICIPATE IN ALL THE
CEREMONIES THAT YOU HAVE IN YOUR
DISTRICT. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HONOR THOSE THAT LIKE I SAID --
KERR CURRENTLY SERVING BUT THOSE
THAT HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES
DEFENDING THE FREEDOMS THAT WE
SO MUCH ENJOY TODAY THANK YOU
SIR FOR THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM LATER.
SENATORS IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR.
LAST CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN NINE MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION YOU SEEN OUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEARCH ALLERGIC TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
AND MY COLLEAGUES THANK YOU I
KNOW THAT EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU HAS FAMILY MEMBERS FRIENDS.
AND PEOPLE YOU REPRESENT MEN AND
WOMEN THROUGHOUT THIS GREAT
STATE.
THAT SERVE AND HAVE SERVED OUR
GREAT COUNTRY AND TO BE ABLE TO
SHOW YOUR APPRECIATION THIS TAX
DURING THE MONTH OF MAY AND
ESPECIALLY A MEMORIAL DAY IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL.
NEED TO DO TO SHOW OUR LOVE OF
THIS GREAT COUNTRY AND OUR MEN
AND WOMEN SERVING AND I THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WOULD LIKE TO ASK ONE LAST TIME
MANY OBJECTION UTILIZING OR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEE NO OBJECTION EYES
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
GO BACK TO OUR GOVERNOR
APPOINTMENTS.
WE HAD A FEW MEMBERS THAT WERE
OFF THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME THAT
WERE APPROVED BY THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S OFFICE.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
GO THROUGH FILE ITEM FOUR
THROUGH EIGHT STARTING A FILE
ITEM.
FOR MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS HI [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
HI.
I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE POINT
MAN IS A CONFIRM.
MEMBERS ARE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM.
FIVE MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
I WIENER.
AYE.
AYES THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
POINT IS CONFIRM.
FILE ITEM.
SIX MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS.
I BURGESS WIENER [inaudible]
HI.
HI IS.
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS.
ZERO THE POINT IS CONFIRMED FILE
ITEM.
SEVEN MR SECTOR HE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
BY. FIVE THIRTY THREE KNOWS ONE
THE POINT IS CONFIRMED.
LAST ITEM UNDER GOVERNOR
APPOINTMENTS FILE ITEM MAY.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS.
HI GORGEOUS [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BY.
MORRELL.
HI.
WIENER [inaudible]
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO POINT MINUTES CONFIRM.
MEMBERS WE HAVE.
UNDER THE DAILY FILE CONSENT
COUNTER IN THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR.
MISTER SECURITY MISTER SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE AN ITEM
UNDER THE CONSENT COUNTER OR
PASS ESPECIAL CONSENT
[inaudible]
CENTER HUESO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TO MOVE SB --
SIX FIVE SIX FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS.
YES SCHOOL NOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
MEMBERS ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO BE REMOVED UNDER THE CONSENT
OR SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR.
HEARING XENON MRS SECTOR CAME
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINETY NINE SIX A
ONE SEVEN SEVENTY NINE SEVEN
EIGHTY SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE SIXTY EIGHT AND ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
SEVENTY SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CAMBIADO.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HI HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WAS SO.
HI -- TITLE BY JACKSON
[inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
I'M.
I MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL BY NELSON.
BY PM.
BY PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY.
I WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
MR SECTOR CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE [inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
ALL RIGHTS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
CONSENT COUNTERS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE.
A COUPLE OF BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
SET WILL BE RUNNING TODAY AS
WELL AS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
IT'S NOW TIME TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
IT COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
[inaudible]
CENTER PORTANTINO.
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE AT ELEVEN
O'CLOCK IN ROOM FORTY TWO OF
THREE THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR.
CENTER PAN THANK YOU.
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE WILL
CONVENE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE AFTER THE CONCLUSION
ADJOURNMENT OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MRS CENTER
[inaudible]
SENATOR RUSSELL.
YES SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR WILL BE
MEETING.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY THANK YOU MADAM
CENTER.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR THE DAY GOOD
MORNING CENTER SKINNER.
YES COLLEAGUES.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL
MEET FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER
GERMAN IN ONE ROOM ONE THIRTEEN
THANK YOU SENATOR.
LAST CALL FOR COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
HEARING SEEN NINE MEMBERS WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE.
TO AND RETURN TO ROOM -- MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE TIME
TO ADDRESS THE BODY WITH A
JOURNEY MEMORIES WITH ACTIVATE
TO START WITH SENATOR DR SO -- I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
A GOOD FRIEND GARY STEWART.
HE PASSED AWAY ON ELEVEN APRIL
ELEVENTH AT THE AGE OF SIXTY TWO
HE HAD A LIFELONG PASSION FOR
MUSIC.
AND THE LED HIM TO BE A FORCE IN
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY FIVE YEARS HE
WAS PREVIOUSLY SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT.
OF ARTISTS AND REPERTOIRE FOR
RHINO ENTERTAINMENT WHERE HE
TRANSFORM THE ORGANIZATIONAL
CULTURE FROM PAID VOLUNTEERISM
AND CORPORATE GIVING TO
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING.
HE WAS HIRED BY APPLE STEVE JOBS
TO TRANSFORM THE COMPANY'S
FLEDGLING I TUNES MUSIC SERVICE.
AND EVENTUALLY HELPED CURATE
PLAY LISTS IN MUCH THE SAME WAY
HE CRAFTED ALBUM RELEASES.
HE DEDICATED NEARLY THIRTY YEARS
OF HIS LIFE TO SUPPORTING
NUMEROUS NONPROFITS INCLUDING
THE LIBERTY HILL FOUNDATION
WHOSE MISSION STRIVES. FOR
EQUALITY AND JUSTICE HIS
PHILANTHROPIC ACTIVISM WAS
CENTERED AROUND LIVING WAGE
IMMIGRATION RACIAL JUSTICE MERRY
G. QUALITY AND MANY OTHER CAUSES.
THAT IS MADE LOS ANGELES A MORE
JUST AND KIND CITY FOR COUNTLESS
PEOPLE.
HIS PERSONAL OUR FRIENDSHIP BUT
WAS VERY IMPORTANT IN THIS
COUNCIL WAS INVALUABLE HIS LOVE
OF MUSIC AND HIS PASSION FOR
MUSIC SPILLED OVER. TO THE
SOCIAL JUSTICE MOVEMENT HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS BROTHER MARK
STEWART.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING
GERRY'S LEGACY AND SEND IN OUR
HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES TO THE
FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
SEN DRAWS A PLEASE PASS ON OUR
SYMPATHIES TO THE FAMILY CENTER
MITCHELL ON THIS ITEM YES PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT -- I
SERVED ON THE LIBERTY HILL
FOUNDATION'S BOARD WITH GARY FOR
MANY YEARS -- HIS -- A CERTAIN
PASSAGES BUT THE ABSOLUTE SHOCK
TO LIBERTY HILL -- GRANTEES AND
FOUNDATIONS STAFF AND BOARD
MEMBERS PAST AND PRESENT SO I
JUST WANTED TO STAND AND ALSO --
EXTEND MY CONDOLENCES TO THE
ENTIRE SOCIAL JUSTICE MOVEMENT --
FOR LOS ANGELES THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
AND I THINK OUR GAVEL JUST BROKE.
MEMBERS SEE IF WE COULD JUST
PLEASE TURN OUR ATTENTION TO
CENTER MONEY PLEASE.
THANK YOU A MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ASK YOU
TO JOIN.
IN THE ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY OF
DORIS DAY AN ACTOR SINGER ANIMAL
RIGHTS ACTIVISTS BUSINESS WOMAN
AND PHILANTHROPIST.
EARLIER THIS WEEK THE DOOR STAY
ANIMAL FOUNDATION AN
ORGANIZATION SHE STARTED AS A
LOCAL GRASSROOTS RESCUE
ORGANIZATION WHICH INVOLVED TO A
NATIONWIDE NON PROFIT.
THAT PROTECTS AND DEFENDS
ANIMALS IN THE PEOPLE WHO LOVE
THEM ANNOUNCED HER PASSING AT
THE AGE OF NINETY SEVEN DORIS
DAY WAS SET TOP BOX OFFICE DRAW.
AND RECORDING ARTIST KNOWN FOR
FILMS SUCH AS PILLOW TALK AND
THAT TOUCH OF MINK AS WELL AS
FOR RECORDINGS SUCH AS WHAT WILL
BE WILL BE.
QUE SERA SERA.
WELL DORIS DAY WAS KNOWN
PUBLICLY AS THE GIRL NEXT DOOR
HER REAL LIFE DID NOT MERE THIS
PUBLIC IMAGE.
IN HER AUTOBIOGRAPHY.
DORIS DAY HER OWN STORY SHE
CHRONICLED HER THREE FAILED
MARRIAGES FINANCIAL RUIN AND HOW
SHE WORKED TO RESURRECT HER
CAREER.
AS A CHILD DOOR STATE DREAMED OF
BEING A DANCER.
HOWEVER AFTER A LEG INJURY AT
THE AGE OF THIRTEEN DISCOURAGED
HER FROM THIS PATH.
IN DURING HER RECOVERY DORIS DAY
BEGAN TO SING ALONG WITH ELLA
FITZGERALD SONGS SHE HEARD ON
THE RADIO.
HER SINGING CAREER IN JAZZ AND
BLUES LED TO HER CAREER IN FILMS
AND THEN TO A POPULAR.
TELEVISION SPECIAL.
WHEN DORIS DAY RETIRED FROM HER
ENTERTAINMENT CAREER SHE STARTED
THE DOOR STATE PET FOUNDATION
NOW THE DOOR STATE ANIMAL
FOUNDATION AND THE DORIS DAY
ANIMAL LEAGUE AND NATIONAL
NONPROFIT CITIZENS LOBBYING
ORGANIZATION?
WHOSE MISSION IS TO REDUCE PAIN
AND SUFFERING AND PROTECT
ANIMALS THROUGH LEGISLATIVE
INITIATIVES SHE ALSO FUNDED THE
DORIS DAY TERRY MELCHER
SCHOLARSHIP.
AT THE UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF
VETERINARY MEDICINE.
A LONG TIME CARMEL VALLEY
RESIDENT DORIS DAY WAS WIDELY
KNOWN AS OWNER OF A PET FRIENDLY
HOTEL.
THE SITE PERSON IN CARMEL WHICH
OPERATES A BAR THAT HOSTS BOTH
HUMANS AND TO PET GUESTS.
DORIS DAY LEAVES A STRONG LEGACY
IS A GIFTED ARTIST A TIRELESS TO
ANIMAL RIGHTS ACTIVIST AND
PHILANTHROPIST COOL DEEP.
WHO WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME
TODAY AS WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF DORIS DAY THANK YOU?
THANK YOU CENTER MONEY THANK YOU
FOR ADVANCING THAT. FOR A VERY
SPECIAL PERSON FOR ALL OF US AND
ESPECIALLY IN YOUR DISTRICTS ARE
THANK YOU.
CENTER ATKINS ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
CENTER MARIA.
I THOUGHT WE WERE DONE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
INJURE AND IN MEMORY OF A CALLIN
MESA CITY COUNCILMAN JAMES HYATT.
WHO'S BORN IN ARKANSAS IN
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR AND HIS
FAMILY -- CAME OUT NINETEEN
FIFTY FOUR TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HE PLAYED FOOTBALL
FOR ORANGE COAST COLLEGE AND AT
THE TIME I DIDN'T KNOW THIS.
BUT ORANGE COAST WOULD IN
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE WAS PICKED
TO PLAY IN THE JUNIOR ROLES BALL
GAME IN WHICH THEY WON IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE HE MOVED
HIS FAMILY TO CALLUM MESA AND
THEY BECAME.
INVOLVED IN THE COMMUNITY AND HE
WAS ELECTED TO THE FIRST CITY
COUNCIL.
JIM ALSO SERVED -- AND WITH THE
LIONS CLUB THE KALAMAZOO CHAMBER --
VALLEY MESA GARDEN CLUB.
AND MANY OTHER THINGS WHICH HE
DID -- HE ALSO SERVED ON THE
CITY RIVERSIDE TRANSIT AGENCY
THE CONSERVANCY AGENCY WESTERN
RIVERSIDE COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT.
IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS SO --
VERY -- BUSY MAN AND DEDICATED
TO HIS COMMUNITY AND OF COURSE
TO HIS FAMILY HE SURVIVED THAT --
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE BRENDA
IN HIS CHILDREN ROBERT IN KERRY --
HE ALSO.
HAD A A NUMBER OF EIGHT
GRANDCHILDREN SO MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING TODAY IN A
JOURNEY IN A MEMORY OF CHALAM
ASUS CITY COUNCILMAN.
JIM HI THANK YOU CENTER MORALE
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT FORD
PLEASE PASS ON OUR DEEP
CONDOLENCES TO THE ENTIRE FAMILY.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS.
PROTEIN MACHEN'S THE DESK IS
CLEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I WAS --
JUST LOOKING FOR A BI PICTURE OF
MYSELF DANCING WITH MY DOG JOEY
AT THE DORIS DAY -- HOTEL IS MY
COLLEAGUES DISTRICT -- ANY RATE
TO FIVE ON ON MANY POSITIVE
NOTES TODAY I KNOW THIS IS HAS
BEEN A DIFFICULT WEEK AND I KNOW
THAT WE'VE GOT SERIOUS WORK --
COMING AS WE FINISH SESSION WITH
BUDGET AND A PROBE SO I JUST
WANT TO REMIND US ALL -- TO BE
KIND TO EACH OTHER.
AND GO HOME AND ENJOY OUR
DISTRICTS.
AND I WILL SEE YOU ALL AGAIN ON
MONDAY MAY TWENTIETH AT TWO PM
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH MAN APPROACHED HIM
MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL ALL LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS.
IS RECEIVED AT THE DESK WILL BE
RECONVENING MONDAY AT TWO PM
ENJOY THE WEEKEND IN.
GET READY FOR BUDGET NEXT WEEK
WITH CHAIRWOMAN MITCHELL